how are you doing sir
brother it's been a minute it has
actually last time was i believe a liam
neeson movie
there you go what what's uh what's the
mustache is this what role is this or is
this just you
yeah this is the role of jai courtney on
a
what day is it tuesday right
well i never know i mean you work a lot
it could be for a movie
it might be for a movie i just don't
know yet we'll see we'll see
when the cameras roll if i've still got
it or not uh
like to keep my options open but um but
yeah i don't know
i've just finished on something and i'm
heading off to something else soon so
it's a little in between uh you know
slug on the top lip why not
okay so i got to start with the most
important question for you um
yes why did you leak the suicide trailer
suicide squad trailer
against the wishes of warner brothers
and james gunn
well i don't really care what they think
i'm just uh you know
figured like bugger it just drop it you
know time to sort of
get it out there and uh i felt like the
fans
deserved it a little early so um there
you go
i'll probably get in trouble for it but
it wouldn't be the first time i've been
in trouble with them so
it's all good man i thought it was so
crazy like i saw everyone do all the
cast
doing this and i'm like no one is going
to buy this and then i see on twitter
people actually buy this [ __ ]
and i was like oh my god like people
really
i just couldn't believe it i was really
surprised
well it's marketing 101 mate
apparently i jumping into why i get to
talk to you um
what was it about this project the
script that said i want to do this
uh it was a few things it was uh
i don't know the chance to kind of play
these
multiple sides of a character that you
know almost feel like
two roles in one film uh which was a lot
of fun
and i just saw a chance to to explore
some new space
in this action comedy kind of genre um
danced in that realm a little bit but
the action
stuff is really not for me in this film
and
he's more of a sort of a genuine
almost earnest tender type uh in justin
and that's not something i get to do a
ton of so um
whilst it almost felt like a comfortable
kind of room to be in
it was um challenging for me in in in
other ways and uh
yeah i just kind of was thrilled to be
along for the ride when tanya
uh boarded the project i was thrilled to
to hear about that and
uh lucky enough to be invited along she
directed me in an independent film
called buffalo
a couple years ago which i had a lot of
fun working with her on and
i'm a huge fan of kate's and then they
had this amazing
uh ensemble cast with uh stanley tucci
and bobby carnivale laverne cox
susan sarandon so i was like man come on
like it's a it's a no-brainer and when
they uh
when i got the call i was uh i was on
the next flight
also the you uh you do play a character
that i've never seen you play before
um i don't want to get too specific but
uh beginning of the film
i'll say it like that yeah it's exactly
it's like a little bit of a different
kind of
shade to i think people are used to
seeing me in and
that it's tough i mean look honestly i
i've said this a lot like the action
stuff comes
you know that's fairly comfortable
territory for me i love doing that work
i love all of this work
um i really am grateful every day for
for what i get to do
but um but but playing characters that
are a little more genuine or earnest
it's tougher for me the villains tend to
have more fun that's my
that's my kind of that's my comfy space
but um
when i got to be real and authentic
that's when i like get rattled a bit so
it's
it's good to challenge yourself once in
a while being honest about this how
tough is it to pretend to be in love
with kate
[Laughter]
gruelling experience yeah just masks up
all day long
she's pretty lovable man she's uh she's
a lot of fun to work with
um and uh you know such a great talent
i didn't realize how hilarious she was
she's she's very sharp
uh kept me on my toes for sure and uh
great energy to be around so
yeah it was it was cool i love learning
about the behind the scenes on the
making of a movie so
what do you think might surprise people
to learn about the making of jolt
laverne cox's uh opera singing was
uh was uh
it was there that's for sure really a
lot of the time
yeah she's got it she's got she got
pipes of gold like don't get me wrong
she can sing but um
you got to uh you gotta you must tear up
if you haven't spoken to her yet but um
yeah fantastic opera singer i did not
know that
um yeah i got that's that i'm gonna have
to work
uh into the future uh switching gears
for a second
have you seen the finished cut of
suicide squad
yes and your reaction was
holy [ __ ]
i heard it turned out great it's really
good dude
it's super cool it's a lot of fun it's
massive
um i love what james did with it uh
it's you know it's it's [ __ ] it's gonna
it's it's dope i think fans are gonna
love it
i hope everyone gets out to the cinema
to see it i know
times have been tricky uh and that's not
something that you know
the way we get our content now has sort
of changed a lot and it's
equally great to see uh films reaching
audiences in the
the comfort of their homes um but uh but
i think it's a great big summer movie
and
and and people should go and um get a
bucket of popcorn and enjoy it
completely i i completely concur there
is nothing like seeing a movie in a
movie theater it's so cliche but it's
really true the thing that i've taken
away from the new trailer today and the
other footage i've seen is that
it's really funny and it also has crazy
action is that
pretty accurate yeah definitely it does
deliver in those areas
for sure it's also gruesome you know
it's r rated this time round which is um
it's a little different you don't get
too many of these comic book
adaptations um that are that are
hardcore
are uh so i feel like that gave james
license to kind of do whatever he wanted
with it and
um i think audiences are gonna lap that
up
it's the perfect franchise property to
to play in that space um and so
uh yeah i think um yeah i think we're
gonna really kind of
uh bring it home with that i'm curious
about this black site project that you
did
uh what can you tease about that oh yeah
uh black site
uh it's kind of what to say about it i
mean it's a
it's a joint forces
uh kind of special ops covert
uh bunker you know thriller thing in the
middle of
um in the middle of nowhere uh it's
weird it's almost like
uh it's almost like alien in a
cia interrogation facility or something
like that
um although the monster is human uh
it's uh it's it's cool a lot of fun
great working with some cool people i
got to go home and shoot that
jason clark michelle monaghan some other
fantastic talent some really great
friends of mine
uh in the film as well and uh and and
sophia banks
uh first time feature director but super
exciting
um uh and i can't wait to see what she
does
uh next i was i was thrilled to be a
part of her first
uh feature film yeah i'm looking forward
to seeing that i gotta go
uh listen always great talking with you
thank you so much